and so you're married and you um and you
have a special and well you had a
special before but in Netflix why did
you want to go do a Netflix special
because I I asked that and and I I I
think it's worthy of it sure it's it's
worth watching worth having but I think
uh spit it out Howie I could take it
come on as opposed to YouTube where
everybody has access to it where not
everybody is going to want to pay the 15
a month or whatever it costs now for
Netflix right go watch it it's a good
question I know well YouTube I did it I
conquered I came I saw on the guy's back
and then I said well let's go to a new
one and maybe get some new people you
know because they you already got the
YouTube audience let's get a new
audience the YouTube audience is the
world though well Netflix is global as
well
but it's not free Netflix is pretty big
I think most people have Netflix only
access to Netflix you know when I was a
kid and I was when I was your hit his
age and I was doing specials you know
the the thing to go for was the HBO
special those days are over I know you
made me in the I don't want to give away
any of your jokes but it was very funny
in soups and nuts you talk about I can't
believe you watched I'm honored this is
wild HBO being like porn a little bit
but I don't want to give I don't want to
give away your jokes but but it's worth
it no spoilers you will laugh from
beginning to end even even the way
you're um you're um introduced uh-huh
it's very funny oh boy all right I
appreciate it well you gotta get a joke
in any way you can but but Netflix it's
it's like the lady that you couldn't
bang in high school and now you can
finally bang her and uh you're not gonna
pass up that chance
okay meaning like I couldn't get a
Netflix special years ago I was always
trying they wouldn't answer the phone
and then I finally got there so when
they say hey meet me in my hotel room at
nine o'clock
I'm going now since you conquered that
would you do it again
maybe but Netflix is a new deal I don't
know if I'm supposed to divulge this but
no but I know they don't give you the
money they don't give you a ton of money
but I think if you come back did they
invite you to the dance again I think
that's when the Moolah goes up
that's in in fact oh I don't want to
give away that that's a very funny
opening the way that you talked about
your show you can give it away yeah so
so they said you know the people that
brought you uh Chris Rock Dave Chappelle
and and Seinfeld and Seinfeld and
everybody Kevin Hart and all these big
Netflix specials with all the money they
spent on those this was the little money
that they had left over right yeah
ladies and gentlemen with a couple of
bucks you got left yes you got ladies
and gentlemen you got this queef that's
me
oh
foreign